Bloomberg News White House correspondent
that Shannon petty piece has looked at
specific challenges for Obamacare and
she has a reality check this morning on
some of the strongest GOP criticism
Shannon joins us once again at the table
always good to see it see you this is
what the finger-pointing has look like
he's blaming everybody else when you
really bore down and look at the real
facts how bad is it
is it as bad as it appears I guess it's
a question it's very bad in certain
markets it's doing pretty well in other
markets and I think these predictions of
the Obamacare death spiral from the
reporting I've done are greatly
exaggerating the problem yes there are
certain markets and there are certain
people who are not doing well under this
law but there are others who are doing
quite well and to characterize this as a
death spiral I think next year this time
there will be people who are doing just
fine whose health insurance premiums
have gone up some but who have not faces
catastrophic situation legs being why is
it different in markets well I think it
depends on the state Tennessee is a
smaller market you had more sick people
sign up in that market in particular
California and New York bigger markets
the general pool of people who signed up
we're healthier and that helps drive
down the costs for insurers overall now
a death spiral actually has a technical
term here what is it well decima you
mean meaning that you know we kind of as
a use on Obamacare is in a death spiral
that's not just hyperbole that's
actually referring to some issues with
the marketplace right and issues with
the marketplace are in some markets the
insurance have pulled out they weren't
able to make a profit the cost you know
and and thus the costs have gone up a
competition has gone down so you have
premiums going way up and you have
people who have no choice of the
insurance plan and that's what's
happened in some of these select markets
that the Republicans pull have really
cited and hammered away at you also have
people even in the markets where it is
doing fine where you know they just make
just enough money not to qualify for a
subsidy but they don't make enough money
where insurance is affordable so you
have those people who are kind of in
this in-between area who we also hear
about who are paying $400 a month for
insurance and have a three thousand four
thousand dollar deductible so it's it's
not affordable for them and they don't
have really other options are there
band-aids to make this work so that it's
not
going to explode yeah I think this
solution is going to be something that
Republicans really don't want to hear
which is more subsidies and more
regulation a bigger carrot and a bigger
stick if the penalty went up for people
who don't buy insurance more healthy
people would be driven into the market
if the subsidies went up to help pay for
people to get insurance then more people
would be able to afford it and they too
would go into the market and if more
regulations were placed on insurers to
force them to sell in certain markets
that could also help too
you know but those aren't the free
market solutions that the Republicans
want to hear the Republicans Democrats
ever agree on that I think at this point
it is possible that there is more in
common between the Democrats and the
moderate Republicans then there are the
far-right conservative freedom caucus
and the moderate Republicans but that's
not saying much either because the
divides there between the freedom caucus
and the rest of the the Republican Party
it's pretty steep as well but there I do
see there's maybe a potential with a lot
of work and a lot of coalition building
that Democrats could come onboard to a
Republican sponsored plan would we see
another effort by the Republicans to
propose a new health care legislation
unless there's a secret plan that no one
knows about which we've all kind of been
thinking there was some secret plan all
along a month years I mean for people
who have to make a decision about buying
their health insurance this fall I don't
think there's gonna be a replacement
plan there may be some fixes that get in
play and the relationship between Paul
Ryan and the President of the United
States how can these two work together
do you think they're on the same page
now publicly they're saying yes they are
yet the relationship between these two
has never been good it has always been a
tense relationship these two have not
seen eye-to-eye on a lot of things but
they realize they're bound together by
the situations they're in and working
the best they can
this exacerbates the tenseness of that
relationship and there's a lot of people
inside the president's inner circle who
are saying listen the only reason we
were working with Paul Ryan was to get
legislation through Congress he can't do
that
so what good is he to us either let's
replace him or let's push ahead with our
own agenda and stop trying to compromise
so much you think that's the opinion of
deep banham I'm not gonna I will reveal
anyone any certain names but there are
the people in the RNC who's been
with the Speaker Mike Pence is known to
be a close ally of the speaker and then
there was those who came up through the
anti-establishment camp that really
propelled Trump to power who have never
had a favorable opinion of the speaker
what are their initial Chanin I'll see
you back in Washington